what lessons are you going to be
teaching your son as he grows up
handle your boost never get drunk never
get drunk in public never get drunk
period number two
read everything especially non-fiction
whatever book you come across
pick it up read it number three question
anybody in authority it's not like
automatically doubt them but ask why
they think anything get in shape that's
something i deeply regret when i was
younger i did not exercise as much as i
should have and i
ate a lot of garbage not enough broccoli
never go into debt never
go into student debt do you think
university or college is worthwhile in
north america
not waste of time a waste of time and
money what about money in general my
thinking is that you should aim to
save a quarter of your gross income not
net just put it away
you will quickly accrue a great deal of
money and you will not feel that you are
depriving yourself of anything